quand on est maire d'une petite commune
et que son parrainage devient officier a
listé sur le site du conseil
constitutionnel ça peut être utilisé par
des opposants pour la prochaine campagne
et donc ça peut vous faire perdre votre
poste de maire lorsque c'était pas
transparent que vous donniez votre
parrainage à qui vous vouliez s'était
finalement beaucoup plus démocratique
parce que ça ne pouvait pas être utilisé
contre vous aujourd'hui on voit bien que
il ya à la fois les partis qui en jouent
en bloquant ses parrainages et puis il
ya la peur des élus de se dire si jamais
je parraine un candidat de coeur ou
parce que j'ai envie de se le jeu
démocratique soit ouvert et bien ça va
me retomber dessus où je vais me faire
taper sur les doigts par mon parti je
suis en partie d'accord avec vous et en
partie non c'est sûr que c'est un risque
que prennent ces petits maires de
communes mais moi pendant a parlé avec
certains ils sont aussi agacer certains
qui vont donner leur leurs parrainages
sont aussi agacé qu'on les traite de
coire et de voir que leurs autres les
autres édiles et peur comme ça et ils
disent qu'on fait on a eu quand même des
élus de la nation locaux on a le droit
d'assumer ce qu'on veut dire et en plus
c'est même pas dans le conte séquentiel
c'est même pas appeler parrainage
s'appelait présentation c'est à dire ce
sont des élus du peuple qui présente un
candidat en lieu dans leur légitimité
c'est ça en fait finalement et
finalement quand vous regarder dans le
détail en a assez peu qu'ils peuvent
montrer qu'ils aient subi à cause des
communautés de communes à cause des
subventions des conseils départementaux
ou régionaux devraient
vexations ou de vrais privation de
subventions donc c'est peut-être aussi
un risque qui est un petit peu surestimé
je suis pas mère moi même donc je vais
pas parler à leur place mais que cuite
prennent eux-mêmes peut-être trop à
coeur et peut-être certains élus n'ont
pas du tout envie de présenter quelques
candidats que ce soit et ça peut jouer
aussi ça ou alors ils sont peut être
divisée eux-mêmes où ils savent pas mais
c'est moins je trouve que c'est un
risque qui pèse moins que ce qu'on dit
oui c'est pas un risque énorme et
scénariste qui exhibe n'existait pas
donc ils permettaient plus rapidement
plus facilement donner un parrainage
aujourd'hui on sent bien que c'est
extrêmement stratégique
sur l'échiquier national mais aussi au
sein du parti auquel on appartient